♪♪
[ Upbeat electronic
music plays ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ Everybody's looking at
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm the only guy in town
wearing tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ I'm the guy, guy
wearing tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪ ♪ ♪
♪♪
-♪ Everyone in town loves
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ People wouldn't lie about
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ I can dance real low,
I can dance real high ♪
♪ I can sleep real well,
know I'm the only guy ♪
♪ That's wearing tight pants ♪
♪ And I'm the only one ♪
♪♪
-Hey!
Hey, slow down there,
old friend.
You say people are
talking about your tight pants
down at the local five-and-dime?
Well, I find that
hard to believe.
'Cause I live in this town,
and everyone I know
is talking about my tight pants.
-Well, I talked to
Mayor Grimble the other day,
and he declared my pants
the tightest in the land.
-Now, you listen to me,
you sick son of a bitch.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know who you are
or where you came from,
but I'm the only one in this
town that can wear tight pants.
You got it?
I will end you.
Don't wake the snake.
Hiss!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You drinking my sake,
Kemosabe?
[ Applause ]
Rock-and-rolla, Ayatollah.
I guess I'll find a new town.
-♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ Everybody's looking at
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm the only one in town
with tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ No one else around
is wearing tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ People wouldn't lie about
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ I can swing my arms,
I can shake my hips ♪
♪ I can dance down the block,
knowing I'm the only chick ♪
♪ That's wearing tight pants ♪
♪ And I'm the only one ♪
♪♪
-Slow down there,
young lady friend!
[ Laughing ]
You say that people are
talking about your tight pants
down at the local Piggly-Wiggly?
Well, I find that
hard to believe.
'Cause ever since I moved
to this town,
everyone I know's been
talking about my tight pants.
-Well, that's funny,
because yesterday,
I ran into Mayor Barleycorn,
and he presented me
with a plaque declaring my pants
the tightest in all the land.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I just received an urgent
telegram from Governor Grimble
proclaiming today as
Tight Pants Day
in honor of my tight pants.
-Listen up, you little bitch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You better hide your wife!
You better hide your kids!
'Cause I will cut you!
I will cut your father.
I will cut your mother.
I will scratch you.
Don't make me
take off my heels!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Take it easy, George and Weezy.
-Look, what I'm trying
to say is...
get lost, applesauce.
I'm the only one who can
wear tight pants in this town.
You feel me?
Don't rattle the cage.
Hiss!
[ Applause ]
We cool-o, Papi Chulo?
I gotcha, hot Sriracha.
I guess I'll find
yet another new town.
♪♪
♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪♪
♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ Everybody's looking at
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪♪
-♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
our tight pants ♪
♪ We got our tight pants ♪
♪ We gout our tight pants on ♪
♪ We're the only couple
wearing tight pants ♪
♪ We got our tight pants ♪
♪ We got our tight pants on ♪
♪ We can dance over here,
we can dance over there ♪
♪ We can walk down the street
and everybody stare ♪
♪ We got our tight pants ♪
♪ We're the only ones ♪
♪♪
-♪ Everyone in town loves
my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
♪ No one else around
is wearing tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants ♪
♪ I got my tight pants on ♪
-Whoa!
Slow down there, compadre.
You say people are talking
about your tight pants
down at the local penny arcade?
Well, I find that
hard to believe.
Because ever since
we moved to this town,
everyone we know's been
talking about our tight pants.
-That's funny,
because yesterday I ran into
Mayor Wembley,
and he declared my pants
the tightest in all the land.
-Well, we just welcomed
our brand new baby boy,
and when we told the news to
Governor Grimble, he proclaimed,
"Hark! 'Tis the true heir
to the tight pants throne."
-A new baby, you say?
Well, ain't that a bag of beans.
Especially since you and I
haven't spoken
since that one, magical night
we shared together 9 months ago.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, you listen to me,
you fat-faced cob-knobbler!
I don't know who you are or what
butthole you crawled out of,
but this is my woman,
and that is our baby.
And every night,
he gets swaddled in
the tightest of pants.
We're the only ones
that get to wear tight pants
in this town.
You drinking my sake,
Kemosabe?
-Don't mess with the lioness!
[ Singing "Circle of Life" ]
[ Applause ]
-You sippin' my soup-e,
Guadalupe?
-Point taken, Kevin Bacon.
I guess I'll find a new town.
♪♪
♪ Everybody's talking 'bout
our tight pants ♪
♪ We got our tight pants ♪
♪ We got our tight pants on ♪